hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar 3d cell cultures and
tissue clearing a high content confocal
platform for the complete 3d
characterization of advanced cell
culture models I am Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific
thermal Fisher is a world leader in
serving science whose mission is to
enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity for
more information please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers impression
just click on the support tab sound at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Michael Johnson
PhD the chief executive officer at visit
all physical is a drug discovery
research organization focused on
advanced in vitro models 3d tissue
imaging and digital pathology dr.
Johnson is a 27
Forbes 30 under 30 honoree he holds a
PhD from Rutgers University dr.
Johnson's research background has
focused on various projects from remote
sensing research with NASA to building
light sheet microscopy for 3d tissue
imaging and producing algae derived
biofuels prior to reading visit call he
worked on several biotech based
entrepreneurial pursuits and is very
passionate about translating
cutting-edge research into life-changing
commercial technologies dr. Johnson will
now begin his presentation
excellent well thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak today I'm looking
forward to diving to the presentation
and providing some more details about 3d
cell culture models and their
characterization so before I get started
I just wanted to give a little bit of
background on our company and where
we're coming from
so about visit call our company is a
contract research organization that's
focused on transforming tissues into
actionable insights our company is
comprised of experts in advanced optical
imaging three cell culture models
automation and digital topology and we
provide services in the in vitro
screening space focused on advanced 3d
cell culture models whole mountain
alysus imaging whole tissues in 3d using
tissue clearing and then lastly digital
pathology actually extracting
quantitative data from tissues instead
of taking a qualitative humans we have
an approach to analyzing physiological
slides and H&E IHC labelled slides for
the presentation I was a start giving a
background on 3d cell culturing where it
came from some of the challenges behind
it I'll do the background on high
content screening talk about some of the
limitations of high content screening
with 3d cell culture models and then
dive into three separate case studies
about how three cell culture models are
imaged and characterized so to get
started on 3d cell culture models this
is a relatively new term it's a new
field and it's rapidly growing but why
3d cell culture models the rationale for
three cell culture models and why
they're becoming so popular is that
traditionally in the in vitro space
there's a poor translational gap between
what's seen in vitro studies and what's
seen in in vivo studies and this poor
translational gap results in several
problems when trying to bring new drugs
to market specifically reduce in vitro
selectivity expanded in vivo studies
will bring a lot more compounds too
expensive in vivo studies because of the
poor selectivity of our vitro studies we
have later stage failures and
unnecessary screening and then lastly
increased development cost and time so
because of all these reasons we try and
improve the vitro models that we're
using as they're more inexpensive than
highly complex and vivo models and one
reduce the overall cost of compound
development now to dive into a little
bit more detail why three cell culture
models traditionally we've always used
2d cell culture models these are cells
that are grown as adherent cells on a
plate and why this while this is a
traditional approach biology does not
occur within the body in 2d biology
occurs in 3d and the rationale for 3d
cell culture models is they better mimic
the invivo complex micro environment
that we see within tissues compared to
just growing cells adherent to a plate
and there's been several papers that
have come out of the last five or six
years that have shown the advantages of
3d cell culture models and better
replicating that complex environment
that's seen within tissues better
replicating gradients diffusion and
overall how cells interact with one
another in a complex 3d environment
instead of a two-dimensional environment
before we dive into 3d cell culture
models in a lot more detail I just want
to get the terminology correct and a lot
of the terminology I may use going
forward there's a lot of terms in this
space there steroids there's Micro
tissues there's organoids
and there isn't a specific definition
for one of these types of models these
are used interchangeably throughout the
literature but the term I'm going to use
this presentation is three cell culture
model the rationale for this is that
today there's no consensus on what an
organized actually is or what a micro
tissue or spheroid is so we call all
these terms just broadly speaking 3d
cell culture models now today there's
many ways we can generate 3d cell
culture models and the approach that a
researcher openly takes depends upon
their specific research question the
cost of their research the throughput
they're looking for and the ease of use
that they openly want for their assay
so there's matrix on top and matrix
embedded approaches using matrix L to
actually grow three cell culture models
in a structure there are ultra low
attachment plates where we use an ultra
low attachment coating to grow 3d cell
culture models in AU bottom plate there
is magnetic printing where we have
magnetic shuttles that allow us to
generate 3d cell culture models through
levitation and then lastly there is the
hang drop approach where 3d cell culture
models are created at an actual hanging
drop that causes them to aggregate into
a 3d structure now each one of these
different techniques has its own
individual advantages and disadvantages
and which one you use again is based
upon the specific type of research
question that you have and the
considerations you have around
throughput and cost and ease of use but
to be clear 3d cell culture models don't
replace 2d cell culture models and they
don't replace ad models they have a
specific space in the research continuum
so we think about assays we're always
bouncing relevancy with cost and
throughput we want to only have
something that's very low cost very high
relevancy and also very high throughput
but this isn't always possible we're
always balancing these three different
parameters and any assay that we're
offering
so in this continuum we move from cell
based assays to 2d cell cultures to 3d
cell cultures to atom models and
clinical testing along the way the
relevancy is going up dramatically
as is the cost or the throughput is
going down so 3d cell culture models
fill a niche between 2d cell culture
models and atom models they are more
relevant than 2d cell culture models and
a lot of instances but they're more
inexpensive than atom models they
provide a place in this continuum I just
wanna be clear that 3d cell culture
models do not replace adil models or 2d
cell culture models they'll be continued
to be used in tandem with existing
models allow us to answer different and
more complex questions which I'll get
into in a moment now the benefits of
these models and realize them can be
quite challenging 3d cell culture models
are more relevant in 2d
they have morphology and phenotypes that
are more indicative of what's going on
within the body they're able to better
predict what's going on with the body as
far as efficacy and toxicity they
provide heterogeneous cell populations
and they also provide the fusion
gradients that are similar to what
happens within the body if you think of
a very large molecule like an antibody
and antibody is going to have a
challenging time penetrating to tissues
we're not going to see that in
traditional 2d cell culture models but
we will see that in 3d cell culture
models we better replicate the
physiology of what's going on within the
body through 3d cell culture models but
ultimately 3d cell culture models are a
new field it's only 5-10 years old
really and it's very nascent and because
of that there is a tremendous amount of
literature that's come out using these
models for a wide range of applications
so the field is still very new
researcher is still trying to build
consensus about which models are best
for certain applications which types of
models should be used for
high-throughput or low throughput or
high in vivo relevancy those questions
have still yet to be answered in a
comprehensive way and because of that
this field is new so there's a lot of
questions that are unanswered the
technologies are being developed as
researchers go and a lot of the tools
are still quite new so the weaknesses
around the field are just that it's um
it's nations and also it's more
expensive than 2d cell culture models so
while it's more inexpensive than complex
and vivo models it still is more
expensive than 2d models so it can't be
used a direct replacement for all 2d and
detail applications now
the next background point that I want to
dive into was how we interrogate and
characterize these models this varies a
lot based upon the research question and
based upon specifically the type of data
that we're trying to get out of tissues
but I wanted to make clear here is
there's lots of different ways that we
can extract data from 3d cell culture
models and they vary tremendously in the
price and throughput as well as their
individual limitations so on one end of
the spectrum we have dissolution assays
where we go ahead and we take one single
data point from a 3d cell culture model
whether it's total ATP and we get that
as a single end point from one of these
steroids the problem with that acquiring
this data from a single three cell
culture model is that we only acquire in
one single end point if confocal
microscopy is used instead on the other
end of the spectrum we can actually
characterize every single cell within a
3d cell culture model this process is
incredibly expensive compared to just a
dissolution based assay but it provides
us with a tremendous amount of
information so really designing an assay
is based upon the type of data that
we're trying to acquire from a 3d cell
culture model and that really depends a
lot on our research question and also
that's throughput that's desired in our
assay now one of the limitations today
with 3d cell culture models which is a
poor focus this presentation is
limitations in imaging one of the
challenges with imaging a 3d cell
culture model is that light does not
pass all the way through a 3d cell
culture model and because of that if we
try and image a 3d cell culture model
today of 200 or 500 microns in diameter
using wide field or confocal microscopy
right only passes through about one two
three one two three cell layers into the
model before it significantly attenuates
and because of that today acids that are
based on imaging are only actually
characterizing the periphery of these
models so if you look on the the right
here of this confocal image that I have
if you take a three cell culture model
and you just image it and PBS what
happens as I'm panning through the model
and going up about 10 microns in the Z
direction I start to only see the
periphery of the model the interior is
totally absent as I'm characterizing
none of those cells originally this is
thoughts
due to a necrotic core or simply nothing
being within the 3d cell culture model
but we've shown through using the Saito
Vista 3d cell culture clearing reagent
that if you render these tissues
transparent you can actually image the
entirety of these models so in this case
here we took a 3d cell culture model we
went ahead and labeled it with Sai tox
screen and nuclear stain and then we
cleared it with the Saito Vista reagent
and showed that by doing that we can
actually image the model and its
entirety and increase the number of
cells that are characterized by a factor
of three to fourfold and while with live
field microscopy you can't get the
diseased sections that you can with
confocal microscopy if you clear the
same model image it with wide field you
can also increase the number of cells
that are detected because you're
allowing light to pass through the model
instead of only penetrating about one to
three cell layers into the model the
reason this is highly significant is
that researchers today who are using
live fields or confocal as their
characterization methodology for 3d cell
culture models they're significantly
biasing the results because they're only
characterizing what's going on on the
outside of these models where they're
most exposed to nutrients the most
exposed the compound that they're
looking at and therefore you're not
actually characterizing the entire
population of cells you're only
characterizing the population cells on
the outside of these models which
dramatically biases your results I'll
talk more about that later in this
presentation so we look on the levels
throughout these models as you see here
as we're moving up towards the center of
a 250 micron diameter 3d cell culture
model when we clear the model we see
significantly more cells being
characterized than if we do not clear
the model and this the rationale for
that again is white is not penetrating
we're not getting that signal back to
our detector on our confocal or wide
field system and we're biasing our
results to only characterizing the
periphery of these models
now in designing any three cell culture
model of course characterization is very
important but there are a number of
other factors which need to be taken
into account and the reason for this is
in a 3d cell culture assay these assays
are more expensive we can acquire a
tremendous amount of information if
we're using confocal microscopy and
therefore is very important on how we
design the assays and the practical
considerations of designing a 3d cell
culture assay so the first question that
we always ask is the type of model that
we want to use or looking at 3d cell
culture models we can use a very simple
and expensive model something like Hep C
2 cells in a plate just one single type
of cell up to a highly complex multi
cellular organelle and the difference
there is that the cost of the models is
dramatically different order of
magnitude different for one another and
what we always consider when looking at
one of these assays and building us the
first time is whether or not increase in
the complexity of our model actually
allows us to better answer our research
question so we're always trying to
balance the cost of our assay with a
type of question that we're trying to
answer and also the types of validation
that we need for our specific assay
after we move through the model and
actually pick a model for an assay we're
working on we always then focus on the
minimum amount of data required for our
research question in designing an image
assay one of the biggest challenges that
is around is acquiring too much data for
example if we do 4x imaging versus 40 X
imaging we're talking about orders of
magnitude difference the amount of data
that were used are acquiring and then
also the cost of the assay that were
implementing so always focused highly on
this point here is what is the minimum
amount of data that we need to acquire
to actually answer our research question
because too much data is actually a big
problem and more data is not always
better because it dramatically reduces
our throughput in our assay we then
always think about labeling and analysis
what labels are we going to use for a
research question how are we going to
optimize our labeling to make sure that
we actually have uniform penetration of
antibodies throughout our 3d cell
culture model then how are we going to
process and analyze this data actually
get the type of actual insight we want
from our model and then lastly after we
all this data how do we distill it down
into a single report so this is a
continuum that we as a company always
focus on is always first figuring out
the model that best suits our research
need determining the min amount of data
we need to acquire how we relate analyze
the data and then openly turning large
amounts of data into a single actual
report that a client can actually use to
answer a specific type of research
question now for labeling techniques I
won't dive into this in too much detail
but one of the important considerations
is how we're actually going to label the
model the site of vistit issue clearing
reagent that we had talked about is
compatible with all sorts of fluorescent
probes nuclear stains small molecule
probes is compatible with amido labeling
so we can do two or three channel
emulating with a nuclear stain we can do
fish as well and then also if you have a
model that expresses fluorescent
proteins those are compatible as well
with the tissue clearing re agency
actually image and 3d with all these
different labeling approaches but really
the labeling approach that's used for a
specific research application is just
dependent upon the research question and
access the different types of wesen
proteins and labels that you want to use
in your research now one of the other
important considerations which we've
seen a lot in our work is choosing an
LED vers a laser based system we in our
lab have a CX 7 LCR from thermo Fisher
and we've tried every imager that's out
there we've noticed in the context of 3d
cell culture models there's a large
difference between using a excitation
system and a laser excitation system and
the reason for that is an LED system no
matter how bright it is it's not a
coherent light source so as we start to
image 3d cell culture models we get a
lot of diffraction of light and we see
as we get deeper and deeper into these
models the interior starts to have some
clouding as we're getting darkness on
the interior of the model it's not due
to a lack of transparency it's just due
to a lack of photons actually getting
into the center of the model because
they're diffracting as they're hitting
the cells because we're using a non
coherent light source and what we've
seen through a number of different
assays that we've run is that laser
based excitation always provides clear
and higher quality images than an LED
based light source the other issue is
that we see with LED based light sources
is that with you bottom plates there's a
lot of artifacts on the bottom of 3d
cell culture models that are caused by
LED based system compared to a laser
based system so for our lab and for all
of our collaborators we always suggest
using a laser based excitation system
instead of an LED based excitation
system for 3d cell culture models and we
as a lab we also do a lot of whole
tissue imaging so one millimeter
sections of brain tissues of kidneys
very large hole mount imaging and for
that laser based excitation is always a
better way to go with tissue clearing
than using an LED based light source
next consideration around imaging is the
type of objective that's being used for
imaging 3d cell culture models our
objectives are perfectly compatible we
see a lot of researchers try and use
water dipping objectives and use
expensive optics to image 3d cell
culture models but from what we've seen
it's really a myth emergent objectives
are not required for imaging 3d cell
culture models if you render a 3d cell
culture model transparent with a tissue
clearing reagent you're actually able to
image much deeper into models and the
difference of using an immersion
objective versus an air objective on a
tissue that's been cleared is very very
minimal so we always use always use our
objectives and our imaging and typically
we'll use a 10 or 20 X our objective and
that allows us to image just about any
3d cell culture model to a depth of
about one millimeter
consideration here on the imaging front
is around confocal versus widefield
microscopy now confocal allows you to
image 3d cell culture models in 3d so
actually characterize each and every
single cell within a 3d cell culture
model if that is required for your
research question now this generates a
substantial amount of data and for many
research applications it just frankly
acquires too much data and doesn't
actually help you better answer your
research question but there are many
cases in which confocal microscopy does
allow you to better answer your research
questions so it's dependent upon what
that research question actually is and
comparision wide field imaging is going
to be much more rapid but it's not going
to provide you with depth information
you cannot characterize all the
individual cells within your model but
you can go ahead and get more complete
and a more accurate picture of what's
going on with wide field imaging if you
use tissue clear and compared to just
non tissue clearing if you use wide
field imaging of a 3d cell culture model
today essentially what you're doing
you're capturing about a half half a
circle around the 3d cell culture model
about one to three cell layers deep
you're not characterizing the entirety
of the cell model and you're really
getting a biased picture of what's going
on so wide field imaging is dramatically
improved with tissue clearing but you
can't get the depth information that you
can get with confocal microscopy but
again this is based upon the research
question throughput and the cost of your
assay and then if you do confocal
microscopy a question that we always
receive from researchers is around Z
projections versus stacks traditionally
researchers have always use Z
projections when doing confocal
microscopy so they acquire multiples
East at multiple Z slices throughout the
depth of a 3d cell culture model they
compress all those into one single image
and they process that image which is
referred to as a Z projection the
problem with using a Z projection for
some research questions is that you're
missing some of the vital information
that's within the stack so essentially
you're missing the X Y Z X Y and z
coordinates of individual features for
example if you want to look at how an
antibody is penetrating into a 3d cell
culture model or how dose-response
curves change as a function of depth
you're going
miss that with a Z projection so a Z
projection versus processing a stack
again it's dependent upon the type of
research question that you're answering
but Z projections I would say are much
more commonly used and have much more
traditionally been used than Z stacks
but Z stack processing them individually
allow you to answer more complex
questions and spatial questions about
going on within your 3d cell culture
model and I'll dive into that in a
moment here so the first case study I
wanted to talk about was getting at the
heart of why 3d cell culture models and
why 3d cell culture models provide a
better picture in many cases what's
going on within the body compared to 2d
cell culture models so in this case
study and we call this a personalized
medicine case study here we've gone
ahead and grown the wood cell line which
say breast cancer cell line in 3d and
then also in 2d and what we've shown is
that this cell line grown these two
different mechanisms one approach in 3d
one approach to 2d and 3d we have a
positive expression of ER but in 2d we
do not have expression of ER and the
reason this is interesting is because
within the body this cell line actually
does express ER so we see here is a
better prediction of the expression of a
biomarker within a 3d cell culture model
compared to a 2d cell culture model and
the reason this is important what
they'll dive into the next two graphs
here is that if we don't have expression
of ER within the 2d model then drugs
that might work within the body for this
type of cancer cell line are not going
to be shown to work and 2d models but
will be shown to work in 3d models so
the outcome of this assay if we ran it
in 2d vs. 3d will be different based
upon the nature of how these cells
actually expressed biomarkers in 3d
versus 2d so dive into this on the next
slide here we're looking at ki-67 so
this is a marker for self iteration and
we're looking at this marker in 2d in
blue here and red in 3d and what we show
is for this wood cell line this breast
cancer cell line and 2d we don't see
much of a change for fullest strand as
far as self iteration but we look at 3d
we
a dramatic reduction in cell preparation
and the 3d models with full of strands
that we don't see in 2d the reason this
is interesting is photo strand is an ER
targeting drug that works quite well in
the body but from our 2d assay we
wouldn't know that the 3d assay is
providing us a more complete a more
accurate and a more predictive picture
of what's going to happen within the
body compared to the 2d model so simply
growing the exact same cells and 2d
versus 3d does have a very significant
impact depend upon the nature of the
assay that you're running so while the
2d assay was more inexpensive it was
simpler in this case we've actually
improved the selectivity and the utility
of this assay just by switching to 3d
now the next slide I show us again with
tamoxifen so its maximum reduces
viability and 2d but not in 3d so in
this case here we're looking at from the
opposite perspective we're seeing drugs
that may or may not work within the body
and the expression is different based
upon the 2d or the 3d assay so this is
very significant we're thinking about
designing a new assay is knowing whether
or not the biomarkers that we need to be
expressed in our ass they are actually
being expressed in a 2d model if they're
being expressed in a 3d model and
understand that before we actually go
ahead and run this assay within large
library of compounds because we ran this
assay and 2d the results might not be
indicative of what's going to go on in
the body compared to a 3d assay so next
jumping into a another asset here
another case study example is live dead
assay so in this case we took Hep C to
steroids growing an ultra low attachment
plates we went ahead and processes with
the thermo live dead stain and then
after 45 minutes wash them
we perma Bligh's them we then stain them
with daffy and then we use the Saito
Vista antibody buffer for about an hour
and then we washed them with the Seto
Vista washing buffer and then went ahead
and render them transparence we went
ahead and did tissue clearing with the
Saito veste 3d cell culture tissue clear
reagent and then went ahead to imaging
and we showed here is that higher self
seeding densities resulted in larger
more irregularly shaped steroids and we
looked at quantifying
Daffy and fixable dead cell stain what
we see here is a higher higher
concentration of cells that are dead at
the center of these models with a higher
seating density so essentially we're
doing here is quantifying the necrotic
core of these models and showing how
that's related to the seating density
the reason this is important is until
recently with the advent of tissue
clearing and applying it to 3d cell
culture models a lot of researchers just
simply thought there was nothing on the
interior of 3d cell culture models and
what we've shown by using tissue
clearing here is that we can actually
quantify what's going on within the
product cooler that we can do is very
simple and easy to use axes that are
rapid and easy to implement in any lab
and then lastly the third case study
here is looking at Hep C 2 cell
perforation so very common assay that a
lot of researchers might be running for
self information on different types of
cancer cell lines in this case we're
looking at taxol at varying
concentrations and looking at what
happens during the dosage of taxol
different concentrations so here we did
a pretreatment for 20 minutes we labeled
with ki-67 again for cell perforation we
then went ahead again and cleared the
models with the site Oh Vista three cell
culture tissue clearing reagents and
image and the significance of this is
the difference between clearing the
models and not clearing we're at a
control group here we didn't clear the
same models that were exposed to taxall
and we ran these dose response curves
looking at ki-67 and what we've shown is
there's rheumatic difference between
tissues that have been cleared and
tissues that have been not cleared and
the reason for that is when we're
looking at tax all and the non cleared
models essentially what we're doing is
we're only looking at cells on the
periphery of these models we're not
looking at the entire population of
cells within these 3d cell culture
models but when we clear the models we
are so we see a dramatic drop in the ki
67% of positive cells within these
models when we clear the models compared
to just looking at the non cleared
models because we're actually
characterizing the entirety of the model
and not just the periphery so this has
very large implications for drug
screening and the application of tissue
clearing actually allows us to
completely characterize the model
instead of biasing our results to just
the exterior and then one of the things
that we do a lot of is spatial dose
profiling so in this case here we took
these three cell culture models these
Hep C two models we broke them down into
inner middle and outer cross-sections
and for each one of those sections we
looked at ki-67 percent of positive
cells and this is by processing our data
as these stacks instead of looking at Z
projections this allows us to actually
look at cells within each one of those
layers and determine dose response
curves for each one of those this is
very important for profiling large
molecules is very important for seeing
how our little tiny models are actually
responding to the compounds and that
different components within those models
were actually responding to the
compounds over time
now I appreciate the opportunity to
present about the characterization of 3d
cell culture models if you have any
questions please feel free to reach out
at any time
my email is michael johnson at visit
call comm again I appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you today
thank you dr. Johnson for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Johnson will answer as many
questions as time permits first question
is what is the biggest challenge into
designing a 3d cell culture assay
I would say our biggest challenge is
that we work as a contract research
organization so researchers come to us
and say we have this specific problem we
like an assay that does this it has
these types of endpoints the biggest
challenge for us is the communication
with the researcher around what is the
minimum amount of data that's required
because for example if the researcher
wants to look at their model at 40 X
magnification the amount of data we're
going to generate at 40 X compared to 4
X is about thousandfold more so that
provides a lot of challenges for data
processing for analysis and just only
the throughput of the assay is very low
and the cost is going to be very high so
what we spend a lot of time on is work
with researchers to figure out what is
the minimum amount of data you need to
actually answer your research question
because if we try and acquire too much
data the cost of the assay is going to
make it prohibitive so this is somebody
spend a lot of time on is how do we
design the assay that provides us with a
rich amount of information to answer our
research question but also not too much
information that the throughput is very
low and the cost is very high so I would
say that's our biggest focus point is
figuring out what is that just minimum
that of data that we need I think the
next one is how deep into a 3d cell
culture model can you image with high
content confocal microscopy so this will
depend on the imaging system that you
have and the type of plate that you're
using the most ideal situation is using
an inverted confocal microscope which is
traditional for these assays and looking
on a glass bottom well plate with that
setup you can get to about a millimeter
in depth depending upon the model we
have image several models a millimeter
or deeper but I would say have
millimeters typically where most
researchers will get to with their
standard error objectives on their
microscope that is provided that you
have a laser based excitation source I
would say with an LED based excitation
source again it depends upon the model
but you'll probably be limited to about
200 to 250 microns and depth into the
model this can be slightly improved if
you use dipping objectives but with
tissue clearing it's not going to be
that dramatic of a difference between
using dipping objectives and air
objectives with a
3d cell culture models I would say
safely probably about a millimeter
depending upon the system that you're
using thank you how do your tissue
processing and labeling steps differ
with different types of models one of
the things that we've seen recently is
that a lot of researchers have been
working with neuronal models and we
found this very interesting because we
do a lot of work on holdout imaging of
brain tissues so for instance we'll look
at one millimeter thick sections of a
mouse brain we can image all the way
through they're on a high content
confocal system with our cx-7 lzr
but we notice quickly that with neuronal
serial-in models they are incredibly
dense much dancer than just regular
mouse brain tissue it actually is quite
challenging to label an image the rohtul
models compared to liver models or
several other types of cancer models
that we've looked at so for something
like that that's very dense the
incubation time of an antibody for
example the dilution that we're using is
going to be quite different than it
would be for a liver model so it really
depends on the type of model but for
very dense models like the neuronal ones
you do have to change your processing
steps you might just have to extend
steps for longer you might have to add
more triton you might have to change the
way the tissue is processed but it's
really going to depend on a case-by-case
basis we see a huge amount of diversity
and the types of models that researchers
are working with and what we typically
suggest is always spending upfront time
optimizing the tissue clearing and
labeling process before trying to dive
into developing and executing a
full-blown assay so you can actually
demonstrate that you're achieving
uniform labeling prior to actually
trying to implement an assay so instead
with upfront optimization any model can
be processed and labeled but it does
take time and it will differ depending
upon the type of model that you're
working with thank you your next
question is when is tissue clearing
beneficial for 3d cell culture assays
and when is it not
right so I think it's very important to
be transparent about this and about 3d
cell culture models in general 3d cell
culture models are useful for some
applications but for other applications
they're too expensive and not that
useful so for when tissue clearing is
beneficial it's the same thing if we're
trying to characterize a 3d cell culture
model and its entirety tissue clearing
is very beneficial for use with confocal
microscopy if you're doing widefield
microscopy again tissue clearing is
going to be very helpful to improving
the signal improving the number of cells
that are being characterized and
improving the accuracy of your assay but
outside of those 2 imaging based
applications tissue clearing isn't going
to be that beneficial if you're doing a
simple dissolution based assay of course
tissue clearing is not going to provide
you with that much utility but for any
type of imaging assay of a 3d cell
culture model I'd highly recommend using
tissue clearing to improve the number of
cells that you're characterizing and
unbiased in your data through actually
characterizing the whole population of
cells thank you looks like we have time
for one more question how do we process
optical v slices from a 3d cell culture
model this is a good question so I would
say until recently most research has
always used Z projections to process
their three-dimensional data and I think
this is one of the reasons why a lot of
researchers never really noticed per se
this bias around characterized in the
periphery of their models because if you
think of the projection of all of your Z
slices and you crunch them all together
it looks like you're characterizing the
entire model and you don't really see
those Center Z slices where you only
characterize the periphery that's what
most researchers have done because
limitations of that approach and the
inability to get spatial information
we've started to move away from that and
actually process the individual Z slices
the way we do that is we export the TIFF
images from our cx-7 lvr and we've
written a series of pipelines in image j
and cellprofiler to actually process
those individual Z slices so that's
typically our pros doing it is
processing it on our own and wiring as
much data as we possibly can for our
specific types of research projects
that is on a case-by-case basis the
projects that we do are very diverse in
nature based on the research question
and it really depends on what
specifically a researcher is asking for
in regards to why we use these slices
versus Z projection so it depends but
most of that work we've done an image J
and cellprofiler I would like to once
again thank dr. Johnson for his
presentation do you have any final
comments on the only comment I have is
so I appreciate the opportunity to speak
today I really appreciate lab roots and
thermo Fisher Scientific allowing us
this opportunity if there are any
questions feel free to reach out we're
very interested in collaborating with
researchers and helping out any way we
can thank you I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through February 2019 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye